Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Hello, everybody.
Because of my ears, I haven't been able to stream with my
headphones on, and it's so strange.
I feel like I'm just...
I wonder if you guys can even hear me.
I feel so strange.
Because I feel like I can't hear anything.
chat frozen I got you I got you
you talk through your mouth though I know but it's so
strange that like I can't hear how the audio sounds in my
ears I don't know Vinto is the cutest the whole world stop
hello my hot blood and burning idol Vinto
Did you guys watch the music video?
For those who don't know, we released a new song yesterday.
Woo-hoo!
I don't know when we'll be able to all collab together to
talk about it.
So I feel like I'll talk about it a little bit now.
And then we can play the game.
I think this game is rather short.
shorter stream is good today i need to pack a lot so ouch so
um i had a feeling the song would be a hot blooded anthem
from the chance but i didn't think you would actually go the
tokusatsu kori good job beating up steiner proud of all of
you thank you we commit to the bit here if that hasn't been
proven enough maybe
Thank you!
I gotta know why the Saiyan armor Well, you gotta have
patience, that's what Lominto my burning heroine Thank you
Can he hit us with a mooy boy?
Boo!
Great new MV Here's some money towards Stilts to get closer
to Vicky's hide That's so rude!
Stilts?
You're calling Vicky like a Like a giantess Was listening to
Maybe talk about the behind the scenes a little bit.
Hope you had as much fun filming as we did watching.
It definitely was fun.
Don't get me wrong.
But there was a lot.
It was a lot.
You're laughing, you killed a man on video and you're
laughing.
Actually, I killed two.
Three.
Can you tell us why you were dressed as Vegeta?
I will get there!
Stop asking or I won't answer your questions.
Phoebe said there was a cool Vegeta story.
It's actually...
It's not that cool, I think.
Actually.
I don't think it's that cool.
But I would like to...
We'll watch the music video.
And I'll kind of pause and go through things.
Deprived of my mint knees.
Yeah, you'll never see them.
Any comment on Phoebe killing a kid in the...
No comment?
But yeah!
Yeah, there's a lot to say though.
those who are curious if it wasn't obvious um yes we were
actually at the quarry um um that we were we went there and
the explosions were real there were some people thinking
that it was green screen uh the only green screen that was
used was the puppets um
uh that was oh gosh I perished of embarrassment earlier
because how did you casually find my merch haul I'm always
haunting yeah yeah the black mold green screen okay let me
let me explain okay yes I know Phoebe is talking about stuff
but I will also give my side of how things are my my stories
and experiences as well and then um then i'm sure vicky will
talk about it as well and then eventually we'll all meet up
and talk about our own stories and things that we forgot to
talk about individually uh but it was a couple months ago
that we filmed this um i it was i was extremely sick holy
cow i was i was sick as a dog i the whole time um but uh
here let's Let's watch it, let's watch, let's watch, and
uh...
Yeah, I'll scoot right next to you guys.
And, uh, we can watch and we can talk about it.
Where is it?
You...
One second?
Uh, okay.
okay so there's a very funny story with this with this scene
so i can't i could not stop mario jumping for for one i i
kept being like my arms i could not stop mario jumping um
the uh that we worked worked with oh my gosh i am completely
blanking on his name right now but he is an absolute like
the pro of the pro he has been doing this for like 50 years
like he what if you if you have seen the tokusatsu show he
probably did like the like the the explosions on it
something like you know like that guy was actual like
legitimate um
Thank you so much for the membership.
Welcome, welcome.
Hello, Minto and I was like, you, congrats on the minute.
MVU girls killed it.
Thank you.
But for this, this shot in particular, they were like, what
do you want to do?
And we kind of were like, we want to run sideways and we
want the explosion to happen behind us when we jump.
They explained it to him in Nihongo.
go and uh he just goes
he just sighs and shakes his head and all three of us look
at each other like
um it was also we could not time this for to save our
stinking lives it was it is what it is so funny though the
dramatic sigh he i guess you know um he like we were at this
quarry all day i think we had eight explosions that we um
were able to do uh so to give you guys more of an
explanation um these are the concrete explosions um we did
want them colored like we wanted to get green and but
unfortunately they were out of the colors so we had to go
with the normal concrete and then the other ones were napalm
the the big big fiery explosions those are the napalm
explosions as they were described to us um new song is such
a banger silly like silliness like that is exactly why
you're forever my kami no see also what's the term for when
the group is in oshi that's
um so uh yes um uh this is the concrete explosion uh if i
had to pick between one or the other i think the the gas
explosion is better because you don't realize this but i
have you know my back is open and concrete shoots and so our
backs were like completely covered in like little pieces of
concrete down my shirt and everything like um yeah so uh it
was a little i think the concrete ones were not as great and
obviously they're not as flashy um but they're very iconic
looking with like how they shoot out like that um but yeah
so um uh yes um he i guess because we like we're doing very
like unconventional things with the explosions the
professional was kind of like what the heck are these girls
doing he um wasn't he was not down to clown with us but he
was everybody was very nice um everybody was very nice uh
the whole team was fantastic they if we wanted to do
something they were like very much like okay let's let's
figure it out you know so um we got there around i think it
was 10 a.m or 11 a.m and then we finished around 6 p.m so it
was a pretty full day um uh and yeah pretty full day sorry
the iboos probably bought all the green explosions in our
defense we did it though it's okay i believe you i've
listened to burn on hot blooded heroine like 50 times by
now.
Every time I watch, I find a new detail that makes me smile
from ear to ear.
What a fantastic event, happy six months to dance at soon.
Can't wait for you girls to, can't wait for you girls to go
next day, can't wait for you girls to go next.
Take your first move.
Thank you.
But maybe it's good for the explosions guy to be super
serious.
You know what, that's fair.
That's very fair.
It would be funny because like, we would be able to, like,
we only had one chance for each shot um but we had a couple
tries to like uh practice and one of the guys on the team
they would go like three two one and then we would do
whatever we wanted to do and then the guy would like jump up
behind us like he was pretending to be an explosion and he'd
go bang
so um yeah yeah the explosives are limited we only had eight
of them so which is quite a lot we had the quarry to
ourselves the entire day if you do ever want to do this um
you can book with like a group of people like rather uh you
book like your time slot and you go and then there's other
like people you kind of like form a half circle around the
explosive and then like you kind of get your picture you get
your shot and then you could go about and do it toy quarry
for the whole day yes yeah so um definitely recommend it's
like truly it feels like a crazy experience you're kind of
in the middle of nowhere in japan um the the train station
itself the train station wasn't even manned like there was
no person at the train station and it was just like an honor
system of touching tapping your ic card out like it was very
very rural and from tokyo it's only about how far was it uh
depending on where you're in tokyo actually from ike bukuro
i think it was about an hour and a half yeah wasn't that bad
oh my gosh not even haunted okay when i tell you that the
staff of the of the quarry were so nice they drove us all of
them drove us back to not just the tiny uh rural station
that we got off on no they took us to the big main station
like they were so nice they didn't have to do that at all
but like they were super duper nice um but while we were
driving back the guy that was driving me um he was he looked
he like looked over at the mountain range where we were just
at and he was like yeah that mountain super haunted I was
like by me no not by me
it's crazy levels of hospitality it was about like a 30
minute drive that they at first I thought we were being
kidnapped I was like because they said oh we'll take you
back to the train station and it was a bit of a hike up a
hill to get to i mean obviously we're on a mountain right so
um so i was like oh they're gonna drive us back to that tiny
train station because they don't want us walking in the dark
that's so nice of them and then um the drive was really long
and then we like first we passed the train station i was
like
thank you so much for the fun get there thank you but um
yeah so i was like are we being are we being kidnapped hmm
but also we had we had a pretty sizable group of us so we
had to take different cars so i'm just sitting in this car
i'm with no other members i'm like what's going on
to say hi are you kidnapping me where hi where are we going
i was all by myself i was scared
but it all i made it back to the train station it was all
good it was all good um but yeah
stronger than ever Pen lights mightier than the sword Pen
lights mightier than the sword That came from my noggin I
had a stroke of genius I was possessed by Shakespeare Pen
lights mightier than the sword
You guys have to realize I've never written lyrics before
Before Den setsu So, I, um, I was like, oh, is this, I mean,
it's cheesy, but I was like, is this like so cheesy?
Like, I was like, is this like so, you know, like, I was
like, oh, you know what, I'm just going to include it.
And we don't have to use it.
It's totally, it's totally fine.
But, um, actually, when we sent Mosaic Wave, uh, they're the
ones that wrote the song, by the way.
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna talk about that more later.
Well, thank you so much for the 15th and thank you.
When we sent them the lyrics, they actually commented on
that line.
And they were like, pen lights mightier than the sword is
really witty.
And I was like, I felt so like, oh my gosh, I can't even...
Oh my god, I felt so validated and so everything.
I was like, oh my gosh.
I was so happy.
In Shakespeare's time, they had to do Otage with candles.
No, they got little jars and put fireflies in them,
obviously.
Because they are pens, but they are not.
Yeah, exactly.
Pen lights are mightier than...
Actually, there's like an old ad, an old...
old otage ad for the company Lumika um which produces like
pen lights and you know the UOs and things like that um but
there's an old ad that they did that compared uh otage they
were like they were like otaku are the modern day samurai
and so maybe I kind of got inspired by that because it's
just like your pen light is your sword because you know it
shows like the it shows like them doing like like certain
otage moves but then like as samurai and stuff so Edward
Bulwer Lytton is smiling in his grave I bet he is in his
grave I'll take the pen as mightier for 100
not gonna lie I've pretended my pen light was a tiny
lightsaber yeah exactly exactly you can't see here but I
have one that has a uh uh minto puppet not puppet why did uh
minto plushy in it and phoebe's is a heart and vicky's is a
megaphone which is so cool we found this and we were like
holy cow this is perfect this got my first paycheck from my
new job so here's a gift for the cutest ghost thanks for the
company always carlos thank you thanks for the pink
congratulations and our oshis are our lords people with
graduated oshis because on Ronan pretty much pretty much
right yeah so everything is I saw some people commenting
being like wow they must have been up really what what time
did they film this at to to have nobody on the streets of
Akiba um it was 5 a.m we met up I woke up at 4 a.m I
remember because I remember hotel in Akiba because I was
like my my place was a little far so I was like heck no am I
going to get up even earlier for the trains and stuff so
yeah it was about 5 a.m.
it was so cold and it was raining hold on I know you can see
the You can see the raindrops.
There's not the phones.
Also, I know there are phones, but just pretend there are
evil radars to find evildoers.
There are radars to find evildoers.
Smartphones, our radars have, have raindrops on them.
Our, our evildoer finding rain, not smart, evil doer finding
radars.
Well, okay, the reason we had this shot too is because the
storyboard, what was it?
The storyboard had us kind of like, oh we get a buzz and we
we discover there's wrongdoings happening loitering
happening but um we didn't have anything else to use besides
our phones so yeah yeah yeah um but yeah it was so cold that
luckily bb has like her cardigan on i think i don't know if
she had another jacket have our huge jackets on and then
they'd be like okay let's record and we'd like throw them
off and run run run over and then film it and then run run
back and put our jackets back on like it was oh my gosh
vegeta was totally like thin as paper it was so cold quote
phones all i see are three mega hyper buster evil loiter
data wait radar detector 9000 exactly exactly so it was it
was really really bad and I will answer your question why
Vegeta why Vegeta um so all of our costumes were from Don
Quixote the night before one thing I do regret about this
whole whole process was not bringing a steamer so that I
could take the wrinkles out of everybody's clothes
that explains the wrinkles yes that's why they are so
wrinkled is because we bought them literally the night
before um but the storyboard that we had made by wea um it
asked for us to all be in actually i really was i was going
to go for a seifuku similar to the one vicky wore but but
vicky is so tall that like she was like this one is this it
honestly it works perfect for her too so we were like okay
you go with that design and i was like i was like what do i
wear because um i was originally looking at like an eggplant
part of so this was the first thing that we filmed thank you
for all the superstars by the way i don't want to lose my
track my thinking track track of uh wait my thinking wait my
line of thinking so i'm not reading them right now but um
thank you so much thank you um the so this was the first
thing um i was pretty worried that the uh so i was worried
that with the storyboard the storyboard kind of made it very
serious right um or at least in when we were looking at it
it seemed very serious and very detailed and very like but a
boom boom like this second to this second you do this in the
second I mean as a storyboard is right and so I um was
looking at it and then I was looking at our budget and I was
looking at how we were filming this at 5 a.m.
and in Akiba and everything and I was like I'm really
nervous that if we are all in Seifuku it will come off to
like serious and I mean obviously now with everything
combined there's no way I think that would happen but at the
same time like like I said this was the first thing that we
were doing of the whole of the whole project and I thought
that because like I thought it would come off as like how do
you say
um like like I said like just too serious when the tone of
the rest I thought that like if I was Vegeta it would not
match the tone the rest of the tone of the music video does
that make sense because we knew that we were going to be
doing the explosions and doing like other wacky things so I
felt that it just needed like something that was like
something there needed to be a little extra goof Vegeta was
the key and also it was cold and i was like if i wear a
seifuku i'll be so cold and vegeta had his little that vest
there is so puffy and it felt it was like a marshmallow so
it felt really good 10 out of 10 no notes maoshi brings a
whimsy yeah like um yeah we did have a dovac he's another
part of setzana he was doing like the shots and i would have
to be the or not I would have to but you know I would be
like you know I went to school for film so I was very like
no no no we must redo this shot it must be tighter do the
framing like this put the camera like this how put it hold
it over Phoebe's shoulder like this I was like I have I have
uh self-proclaimed myself as I'm the self-proclaimed
assistant of of the production even though I'm not in the
credits that's my my title that i gave myself because you
know i wanted this to look really good and i think it does
i'm so proud of it i'm so happy that we were able to come up
with such a crazy crazy um music video and the song is so
great uh when we were coming up with the like the quarry was
my idea uh the explosions were my idea we i can't exactly
remember what we were trying to think of but you know we
were brainstorming the music video for the song and we
obviously knew it was a tokusatsu styled you know genre song
and so i was like what if we just went and did actual
explosions and steiner was like what and i was like yeah we
just go and we have explosions behind us like for real and
then we make it a mixed media thing like we have some
animation because obviously too like animation is very
expensive so if we kind of threw ourselves in there it could
be cheaper and Steiner was like so you want to blow all of
our budget instead on explosions and I was like well yes but
but it would be really cool and so he looked into it and
found that we could do the explosions and I was like yeah
just put little stickers on our faces like like as is like
that and it'd be fine
so you were kind of the ghost director I'm the ghost I'm the
ghostest with the mostest so uh yeah yeah it was perfect it
was it was such a such an interesting experience a lot of
fun a lot of fun um I actually felt like I was like, oh my
gosh, I'm really nervous about doing this.
I think that's also why I became Vegeta for emotion.
I was, Vegeta was like my emotional support.
Emotional support, Vegeta, because I was so nervous about
it.
And people looked at us, me really funny while walking
around, and I was very embarrassed about that.
emphasizing blowing up the budget with explosives.
Okay, to be fair though, I was like, we can just do a couple
explosives and dip.
And Steiner kept adding more.
He was like, actually, I got us eight explosives.
And I was like, okay.
Because the original idea was to do like a couple explosives
and then have, well, have like three different cameras for
different angles.
Like one shooting, like we do the same explosive, but one
camera is on Vicky.
cameras on me when cameras on Phoebe but then it became many
more explosives then then we then we anticipated so yeah it
was it was good it was good let's see oh yeah there was the
thought of like cute movies for our faces but I thought the
stickers would be more goofy like they're very goofy looking
so yeah no loitering oh so one thing also was a lot of the
storyboard had um had uh choreography so we were oh my gosh
we were hammering down the choreography and i was so sick
there's shots of us running after those shots of me running
i would ground like almost puking i was cough i was coughing
so bad i was like we can't do the choreo i i physically
cannot do it it was very very i was i was extremely sick and
i was like especially if it's so cold and and and i and so
early in the morning i was like i'm sorry i really cannot do
it And so, you gotta up your cardio girl.
I had bronchitis.
Shut the fuck up, actually.
What is wrong with you?
What do you mean?
I just said I was so sick.
And you are talking about my cardio.
Ban him.
I mean, you're getting banned.
You're getting banned.
My God.
That's actually so rude, though.
But, um...
yeah it was I was and I I it was really tough that's why I'm
very like upset about it that's why I'm upset about it
because it was it was not a great time it was you know
obviously we had fun it's a great memory looking back on
everything but it was it was a lot so so I was like we had
to cut out so much of the of the storyboard because I was
like I'm sorry it's my fault it's my fault that we had to
change so much because I could not do the choreo because I
was so sick even though we like really we crammed learning
it so fast but also because so much of it was cut and we had
to improvise a bunch of stuff we were like what what is his
crime what what did he do like what we need we need a motive
to fight him and so we were just walking around akiva and
trying to like find different places to get shots and we saw
this sign here that said prohibited acts and we were like
loitering
and it was that simple it was us being like he was hanging
around and so that is his crime that is his crime but we do
have I'll show you the one bit of choreo we yeah you can see
the umbrellas
hold on uh this is choreo that's choreo that that's as much
choreo as you got in the uh in the music video he was
hanging out so we killed him yeah hey it's kind of
suspicious to be hanging out there at 5 a.m also i have said
before that the sun rises at 4 a.m in japan this is the
proof this is the proof in the pudding it was 5 a.m and
that's how bright it was isn't that crazy it was so like
yeah um what else what else what else um oh this is kind of
funny because you can tell it's sunset here and then it goes
to daytime because we shot all of these and then we did the
we changed into the other outfits after and it was a full
day of recording and there was three different no well no
there were three different hills that we could film on this
was one and then there was a second one the uh this one uh
wait this where
No, this is a second hill.
It's kind of hard to tell.
And then there's one over there, like behind.
I think it's this ledge up here that we could have filmed
at.
Imagine all the people in the background going about their
day being like, who are these weird girls?
Well, we, um, yeah.
There were a couple people just kind of like, this and I was
like go away go away shot at different times that they
really adds to it does it yeah yeah that's a great so good
so good okay there is a here so obviously they edited us in
But...
This...
Imagine us not in this, and it's just Steiner flailing
about.
Like, it looks like he's fighting his demons.
It's so funny.
Fight for you!
Why the puppet?
Funny story with the puppets as well.
Again.
We had to...
We had to improvise.
Because we had to change...
So a lot, quite a bit of the storyboard.
Shad came back.
Shad was the one editing the music video.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Shad came out and was just like, I need you guys to go back
and take more footage or take footage on a green screen of
you guys individually.
And I was like, okay, but we all have different cameras.
We all have different lighting.
Like if we take stuff on a green screen, like at home it
will all look very different it'll look kind of funny um and
i no i am not i i was i was not very keen on the idea of
going back to akiba and recording at 5 a.m again i was like
no and i was already going to make the puppets for faname
anyway and i was like well hey guys it's already multimedia
what if we use puppet and so that's how the puppets came to
be as well I'm very proud of how the music video came out
because you know I do feel like I contributed quite a bit to
it so I was like let's do puppets and so we went to this
horrible horrible oh my gosh I was stressing over these
puppets so I was like I gotta get them done and done I was
in my hotel room finishing Vicky up at like 1am in Japan I
was like I gotta I gotta finish these puppets
but um yeah we went to this horrible horrible studio that
was in some basement we opened up the door and we were like
it was so awful the stench there was like this horrible
mildew mixed with cleaner smell that we were like oh my god
my nostrils were burning and we go in there and we open oh
my gosh there was like a filter that just was it was so
covered in dust it looked like it looked like a sponge cake
there was a thing in the corner that was supposed to absorb
moisture in the air and it was completely full of water like
things like that and it had black mold on the ceiling and
phoebe went to pull out the green screen and spiders came
flying out it was just it was it was a studio um we booked
it for two hours and we were in there for 45 minutes we i
think uh this was that was the last trip that we did the
last month um so beginning of may ish yeah beginning of may
and um i think i think i got sick again because of it i'm
not gonna lie i was like holy cow this is horrible still
imagine getting blown up by three cutie cute three cute
magical girls for the most random offenses in Akiba.
We will get you.
So it was, um...
It was...
Uh...
Mint I was that guy.
I'm sorry.
My PC messed up and I missed a chunk of the story.
I often feel sick when I run so it felt relatable.
I'm sorry to say sorry, but it was too late.
thank you scorcher thank you for the apology sorry sorry I
was a little bit of a sore subject for me because I was you
know I was like crying in bed and like I was pretty
frustrated at the time sorry to take it out on you but thank
you sorry your PC also is having issues
yeah but it all worked out it all worked out in the end so
well that ends well.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm bad if I get...
No!
But yeah, so we were in there in the studio for like 45
minutes and we were like, we were like, we gotta get out of
here!
We gotta get out of here!
And um...
Uh...
Also, Vicky couldn't make it.
it that day so that's me i was controlling myself that's me
that's me i i took off my sleeve and i was like okay i'm
gonna wear a white like a white like vicky's gloves that's
me i have two arms yeah
That's me, and that's, no, that's Phoebe.
That's, we suffered together.
I'm glad Vicky was not there because the three of us
suffering in there.
I mean, Steiner was there too, but all of us suffering in
there together would have just, she didn't need to go
through that.
Not to doubt Vicky, but that puppet seems very you.
What, you don't, what, that's a Vicky punch.
I went Vicky punch.
What do you mean?
I love the slow.
Like, you don't want jiggle physics?
I have no jiggle physics, except on my gloomy eyes.
It's so satisfying to watch.
Starring Min Fantom is Victoria Roman.
But yeah.
Vicky punch!
That's VB.
We just played the song and, like, did what?
needed to do it just moves in a very mental way that's not
you would never have known if i didn't tell you you would
have never known you would have never known don't lie don't
lie and then the animated parts oh the clock there is very
iconic and akiba history so i definitely wanted to get shots
of it all the b-roll was
I did two takes of that and they went with that one I was
kind of I was like oh they liked it for real meant the music
video was cool loved it Vicky looked like a mom taking your
kids to occupy what do you mean no i didn't know this part
was i mean this part was so this part was so cool this looks
so good this is a punch punch this is a dying place this
song originally actually was gonna be me um and phoebe in
the first part that we had a a different like idea for it
where I would mess up the combo and then Phoebe and Vicky
would be looking at me like girl come on and I'd be like
well have you done right you do it yourself and then we
would all fight but the reason we switched it was because
was because I sing this part so it would be kind of weird to
have Phoebe if I sing that part and then Phoebe shows up and
then we were like what if Phoebe falls and has big old P and
I's and then we're like then we're like multiplayer mode I
love the camera cracking it's so fun oh yeah like here I
would run and then afterwards I'd be like dying um there was
an explosion like we have other shots of the explosion like
i think we have like a frontal shot of us running um this
part is so beautiful this whole part all the lyrics are baby
it's so it's so cute and you can die
And then the rap was all Vicky.
She wrote all the lyrics to this.
This part was fun though.
It was boring.
I took
this and I wrote this.
Actually, these shots.
We went to Don Quixote because we were so cold.
But also the storyboard, we didn't realize.
The storyboard asked for pen lights.
And we were like, oh, we don't have pen lights.
So we had to go to Don Quixote.
And we had to go buy pen lights.
And congrats on the MV.
It's amazing.
I'm so starstruck that you got to work with Posaic Wave.
Me too.
They were so awesome.
it's it's so cool because like this isn't their usual style
but they nailed it they like oh my gosh they knocked it out
of the park and then there's also little bits in it that
like kind of have like mosaic flair so um actually the part
with the rap it wasn't even like a rap at first it was kind
of like a the way they sent the demo it was very it was like
and so vicky though she was just like I hear this part and I
hear like me rapping in it and it's like doing like a cool
like you know and uh and so we change she changed it up yeah
I find it hard to believe you don't have spare pen lights I
was in Japan I didn't have anything I don't bring my pen
lights every time it's kind of insane that donkey is pen
lights wait no that's like where you go to get pen lights
you go to don quixote for your uos and your pen lights yeah
yeah yeah i have so many pen lights though the one that i
bought i already owned i i left everything at my maid cafe
so i really didn't have anything um i have like i don't know
probably i don't i don't know how many pen lights i have too
many i've always known i'm not alone but now i truly do
believe in my soul corn pizza i like this part because it
says like you know sometimes in akiba uh there will be idols
handing out flyers and stuff but this says like daibukinshi
which means like do not do do not do live performances here
like live performances are forbidden
I want I made sure too the first iteration did not have like
akiba station but I wanted that and momunidoke and these are
not these are not akiba I just took them on the train
because it was so muggy it was so not muggy it was so um
cloudy that's the word it was so cloudy it was so rainy the
weather was so bad for so much of the trip and so whenever
the sun came out i was like i gotta record i gotta record
something because otherwise it's all gonna be gloomy gloomy
and then i asked for the shot to be the zoom in on the sun
and i asked for that
I don't know.
What am I doing with my hands?
What was I doing?
It looked like I just go to pat him, and I'm like, no, no,
no.
I have no idea what I was doing there.
I think I got confused.
I was just like, what am I?
I'm just waving my hands around.
I love the line, one day the NPC will become our new
heroine.
That was like a mix of a couple of our lines, so kind of the
idea of it.
It was really good.
He gets exploded anyway.
And then, then don't you want to just go ape shit sometimes?
Don't you want to just...
Don't you want to just explode everything?
We were exploding and happy.
And this shot too, this was me being like...
I was like, if we're at the quarry until nighttime, I was
like, Dovec, dovec, get us from behind.
I want us to be like, yeah, towards the sunset.
I was like, get this shot.
Get this shot.
Yeah, I tried to help direct shots as much as possible.
Because he also was just like, I don't know what's going on.
And we were like, we got the storyboard.
But we were like, we had to lead a little bit.
I was like, get us from Brian with our hands up in the air.
like this so my proclaimed my self-proclaimed assistant
title at work
um but yeah accepting that yeah i wasn't the popular kid
back then but screw you otaku culture for the win yeah we
really wanted like otaku anthem kind of you know Like, uh,
you know, for this one's for the misfits, you know, this
one's, this one's for the people that, you know, feel like,
oh, I don't fit in.
Oh, people think I'm weird for my hobbies.
Things like that.
And then my costume was Wet Rose.
If you ever get the Wet Rose cosplay, oh my gosh, where is
it?
oh why can't i find it wait i'm going too fast wait oh here
we'll do the mooy mooy this one yeah um it was a little big
on me oh my pants you guys like my pants they're from uniqlo
they're from uniqlo so you can go to uniqlo and get pink
sweats and we can match if you want
I wear them all the time, actually.
But I'm just shy.
I'm just shy.
Have you ever seen, like, girls that wear their Seifuku and
then sweatpants underneath the skirt?
I kind of was like, I want that kind of vibe.
But it's the Wet Rose cosplay.
I ordered it for myself.
Just because I was like, I want it.
It comes installed with like, not installed, like a bra sewn
into it.
And it's like, first of all, it's huge.
It was so big on me.
And the bra is so stiff.
I was like, I don't know how to get rid of this.
Like I couldn't, I didn't want to cut it open.
So it was like falling off of me a little bit all day.
But it worked out.
yeah it was like it's extra padded it's extra padded so if
you get it um yeah i gotta grow into it
padded for dreams sure ayami is nodding somewhere in
approval probably extra storage for spare socks yeah i was
like i don't have time to figure out how to take these out
but whatever it's nice to have a bra in it at least right so
i mean i would i don't know hi minto in your opinion what's
the difference between a weeaboo and an otaku i don't really
see a difference i don't know i guess weeaboo is like a
western term but if you want to be superior otaku you use
otaku i think they're i think they're about the same though
well also i think otaku refers to like any nerd so you can
be like an otaku for plants for example you can be otaku for
trains but weeaboo has a very like anime connotation um
is like somebody that loves anime and Japan I think and then
Otaku is like just a hardcore nerd in whatever they like
yeah yeah
that is indeed what I heard about Otaku yeah I missed the
start of this and I don't know what the context is of the
video or where can I watch it you can watch it on the
Densetsu.exe channel Da-da-da-da-da-da!
Here, hold on!
Uh...
Uh, watch...
Den-Setsu.exe's newest...
Oh, wait.
Newest...
Newest song and...
Wait.
New...
Watch the...
New song and music video.
I'll pin it.
Mighty is the pen line.
Small pants, huge bra.
Who was this made for?
What are you talking about?
But I think that's everything I wanted to talk about with
it.
Yeah.
I think or rather I'm really I'm really happy with how it
came out oh another thing I wanted to talk about too it's
kind of funny but this part the ten sets they kick real good
now we kind of were like well I don't when we were doing the
lyrics we were like what are we what do we do for that part
these are my genius contribution uh den sets they kick real
good now and den sets they do the punch punch i just kind of
said them and they stuck i didn't think they would actually
but um i didn't do the secret combo i think i think febe
febe was really into that one yeah input the secret combo i
know i'm a lyrical genius what can i say what can i say of
my of my time I and the in the collab yesterday they said I
come up with the one-liners and truly I guess I do don't ask
me to do any more though I will give you such things as they
do the punch punch and they kick real good now but yeah um
really happy with how it turned out so so proud of us it was
it was a long long like we had to you know the team that put
the animation and everything and everyone that like worked
on the music video itself like everybody did such an
incredible job like the overall music video I'm just so I'm
so so happy with it and um thank you everybody for listening
to it and commenting on it so much it will be uh it got
submitted to streaming platforms like Spotify and stuff
yesterday so um hopefully that goes through soon and um yeah
everybody did such an amazing job Vicky and Phoebe did an
amazing job everybody did an amazing job a sport for laying
in the in the dirt where like the deer poop and stuff we had
to walk past deer poop several times like in the on the
hills so that guy might have actually laid in poop
we would be walking up the hill and someone would be like
look out to your left oh i do have some like other shots
hold on um some other shots from the the the quarry give me
a second here i'll just play the song while while i look for
them they're quite far back in the one mind
Rise up!
Cause we're stronger than ever!
Raise up!
And life's mightier than the sword!
Fighting on!
Burning like a sun as it sets upon the dawn I love!
Dance, dance, we take up!
Keep up!
The heart is set aflame by a call from all above all!
Dance, dance, we take up!
Protecting one of the sacred rewards!
Kinda get you a bit better of a scare.
Dance, dance, we take up, keep up!
Side by side, until the end of the earth!
Take up the fight!
Building a height before that means Sadness blooms from our
eyes And then half will stand together with you by your side
Standing tall as three with the strength from inside The
spirit of the misfit of me Is through us for a week
We'll pave the way through all the hate Light up from
dajikantama narake Our fighting voice is ringing out all
over the world Never mind
About again, good point to stop Cool Here's some like extra
photos that I got Of the of the quarry blue skies it was it
was actually we were worried because um it was filmed a
couple days after the uh the akiba footage of one it said it
was going to be raining we were we were so worried but it
ended up being completely blue skies we were also worried it
was going to be freezing but it actually was so warm so it
was we got super duper lucky this day You can see Sorry,
it's like so long You can see Like the tent and stuff We had
a tiny little tent there Where we would eat food And The car
Brought the explosives and stuff Yeah So cool So so cool
And then Duh
We have from one of the hills.
Oh.
Ta-da.
Whoa.
Look how crazy.
So, hold on.
Let me get a pointer.
His tippy tip.
So, here was one of the, this was the, one of the concrete
explosions.
Raiders.
Thank you for the rhetoric.
Black mold spider.
Is this Phoebe?
Is that you Phoebe?
Black mold spider?
We really...
That was a 45 minutes of hell that we went through.
One story I told today was about the black mold spider
dungeon.
Oh my gosh.
We went through that together.
We really bonded in there.
We fought for our lives, our afterlives, my afterlife.
Growing up with Power Rangers, this music video was a fun
love letter.
In other news, one of the packages that I'm helping ship out
is headed to the Konami branch of California.
Wow!
Cool!
Thank you guys for the gifted.
Thank you so much.
But yeah, you can see we had to climb all the way up here.
Then there was another hill that we climbed all.
the way and around up here and then there then this went we
are real real it like kind of snakes around and there's the
trailer here that's where we got changed there was a potty
over there it was like the cleanest port of potty i've ever
seen there's our stuff wanted to jump in and say how much i
love the video how much it means to me captures the passion
of the group perfectly congratulations thank you thank you
and then uh This they said this was like a famous this was
like a famous part in like like the basically this is a
cliff It's kind of hard to tell but that's a cliff and like
they you know we tried to have like us The effect of us
jumping down from the cliff, but you kind of see the other
cliff from here too It was it was there was like no there's
no like what's it called
no fence or anything if you tumble you tumble you know so
even though it's my birthday can have a happy birthday
phantom imagine happy birthday
yes yes if you watch tokusatsu you recognize the score yeah
100 um and then uh this is just it in the at the sunset it
was really big it was really cool
seeing seeing it in person and walking around and yeah this
is really awesome very very awesome but yeah let's finish
the song and then we'll play the game oh yeah this is a this
is a game
Oh, I forgot there's another part that's actual boring.
Oh, I'm glad there's another part of my dreams.
Where are we going?
Here.
This is the glorious one.
I love the classic subtitling.
It's too good.
Classic Scooby-Coo-Goo-Goo-Goo.
Classic Scooby-Goo-Goo.
Our voices loud, one with the crowd They shake us up, but
we'll never go down So stand your ground and sing your proud
Our battle cries ringing out through the time Dramatic
We'll pave the way through all the haze Light up from
explosion, explosion
Please stream burn on hot blooded heroin
Thank you for letting me talk about it a bit.
Thank you.
Also, I'm glad I got to talk because I'm on medicine right
now for my ear infections.
And it also makes me so sleepy.
So I need to talk to get more energy.
Vagina implies there's a Goku rivalry in her life.
Matara Khan.
No.
Actually, maybe.
Congrats on the music video.
It's awesome.
Thank you.
My grandma got hit by a ghost of a man.
Kaboom, kaplow.
We never told you, but we found out who officially subtitled
the key visual novel opening endings, and they did the
character.
karaoke subs.
No way!
Really?
They did the karaoke subs for this music video.
That's crazy!
Wait, that's crazy.
Let
me open up the game.
Mint Jita.
Matara is about as killable as Goku.
That's how I feel.
too did she just cannot be put down just thinking for me how
far you chase that loiterer from Akiba the corner yeah well
that's why we took the train all the way there things were
the behind-the-scenes talk looking forward to jam project
doing a cover when yesterday when people were like oh a jam
project song I was like close close it's truly a story of
turning some negatives into incredible positives you three
did so good got the reference thank you thank you brox thank
you so much for 18 months the big strongest thank you for
nine months proud of you thank you i just thank you yeah it
was i was definitely i i was like i was just gonna get done
in time um it was definitely a trust the process kind of
scenario we were kind of like well we'll do this and if it
works out it works out
if it works out it works out if mint is vegeta who's going
to be ghost nappa ghost mata oh chat froze thank you
hmm Maybe mention we might be able to see the original
choreo at the Legends a New Concert.
Oh, yes.
Streaming tickets and online message board on sale now.
If you thought this song was very hype, then maybe you would
also like to see it hype in 3D.
I mean, there is choreo.
We did talk about it.
So maybe.
Good luck with the gaming toy saw.
one trailer immediately purchased a one-way ticket to the
nope train back to f that bill thank you k bar and i'm i'm
very excited now love my cute creative oh she good work on
the music video congrats on six of us agenda to fake d thank
you thank you i'm getting streaming tickets streaming
tickets for the 3d concert are up now as of yesterday
there's also a digital
I think one thing that, you know, VTubers can do so much
because, you know, there's so much we can do virtually.
But also it can feel a little bit hindering.
I feel like sometimes it's harder to, or rather it can be
harder to like, kind of create things that can be relatable
to you guys since, you know, we're digital.
and everything and um you know there's you know we could
always do like a we could always we could always have done
like our 3d selves you know like rather impose 3d on top of
explosions or something i thought it would be a lot more
meaningful if we were actually there you know i don't ever
want to half-ass anything even though i feel like my stories
maybe sounded like we kind of were where it was just like we
don't know what we're doing we're just recording this and
that But I always want to make a point of like, you know,
kind of exploring the medium, being able to push boundaries
of stuff.
So hopefully you guys thought it was pretty cool.
And hopefully we can come up with some more really fun and
cool things in the future.
So please.
keep a lookout and keep your eyes on Densu too and keep your
eyes on our future projects and stuff like that so kind of
like similar to like our 3d concert even like we're kind of
doing a multimedia like we have 3d us in 3d and also people
there in in real life like we're always kind of wanting to
um you know push more and try more in different things so
really feel like it came through with this video i'm really
glad that we could have like such a cool multi multimedia of
a mortgage board of everything it was kind of craziness i
know some people i saw comments being like i had to watch it
multiple times because the music video was so distracting
from this song but this it's kind of fun because i'm a huge
fan of the denpa genre and to me this And it's really fun
seeing people get their kind of dip in their toes in a
little bit, getting their first experiences with this kind
of stuff.
Thank you for all the server chats, everybody.
Thank you.
Every time I watch the Ten Sets of Music video, I say a
little prayer and thank my lucky stars.
I did get exploded.
Not yet.
Your effort really shows.
Thank you.
There's a difference between phoning it in and making do.
and you're you're a pro curon site master your passion comes
through i'll be watching forever thank you so much better
this way you girls did fantastic thank you for working so
hard i think i i i'm you know it was a lot of like changes
and a lot of like like do it this way do it that way um
throwing out ideas but i think it all came together somehow
somehow it's chaotic and unified it's awesome hearing how
much creative energy you put into this really paid off.
Congrats on an incredible music video.
Thank you!
Yes, yes, yes.
Thank you for the super chats, everybody.
Let me open up the game.
Idols of Ash.
Let's play.
I think this game is a little bit shorter, so it's kind of
good that I talked for so much, I think.
But also, I have a lot of packing to do.
so if it is a end up end up being a shorter game as well
sorry about that this is so cool because i know the devs
really well um if i say bad things about it no i'm just
kidding i won't uh um let them know nap night thank you so
much for the five gifted how do i find these games this one
i found through another streamer um but also people were
asking if i wanted to it and i did say i wanted to so um
yeah we are the this is the aftermath of burn on the idols
of ash we burned everything and and now it's all ash i
always think of that line and pokemon in the dub do you guys
ever think of that where they say the world will turn to ash
i i think of that probably at least once a week like I think
I think of that line at least once a week it is so crazy
good it's so oh so basically if you haven't seen Pokemon
2000 they're like there's this prophesied prophecy that says
I can't remember the full thing but it's basically like if
this is not fulfilled the world will turn to ash and so in
their minds they're like oh my gosh if we don't do this
thing the world is going to burn but there's ash ketchup and
and so instead of the world burning it's the world is
turning to ash ketchup because he is going to save the world
cinema it's it's still good it's it's so good it's oh my god
chills it's
i think of it all the time i'm like wow i like i'm not even
exaggerating when i say i think of it at least once a week i
just think of it and i'm like that was such a good line
maybe that's why i have pen lights is my pen lights are
mightier than the sword my my peak writing is the world will
turn to ash.
It is my Roman Empire.
Can we do a Pokemon?
No, we shouldn't do a Pokemon 2000 watch along.
I might scream.
I might actually just I will leave my cafe.
I will just walk down the road and I'll be thinking of that
line.
I will stand in the rain and just that Vegeta gift.
The gift of Vegeta and the rain.
That will be me.
Thinking of the...
I got excited and I just...
I...
I got too much chapstick on me.
Now I kind of want to watch Pokemon movies.
Brother...
My brother...
what are we fighting for we got to end this war we should
love one another
i want to watch pokemon movies
what a throwback i see now it is not the circumstances of
one's birth irrelevant but what one does What the gift of
life is what truly matters Mews This is so good Why is it so
good?
I just overchapsticked myself too Actually before we play
this Can I go get some water?
Before we get all This game does have like big bugs in it So
if you're afraid of bugs I don't know to what extent But if
you're afraid of bugs Maybe This one will be spooky scary
Opening scenes and song of Pokemon Movie 3 remains a core
memory free.
Yeah, I'm going to be switching the audio only from here.
Oh, you don't have to keep it open.
That's okay.
Thank you, though.
Okay, I'll be right back.
Sorry.
When I stood up, I realized I also had to go to the little
ghosty's room, so I astral projected there.
Okay.
I also wanted to say one more thing because I was thinking
about it.
I feel like when about the music video it was like me me me
me me you know it was i felt like you know i was saying a
lot of like i did this and i did that i wanted to say too
that like everybody did a ton of work um i was just giving
my stories so um i didn't want to like cause any confusion
like that like i feel like i did a majority or anything or
you know like everybody did a ton of ton of work and so um
it was just i was just like wait a second i talked about
basically myself the entire time but I was just trying to
give my perspective because I knew that Phoebe gave hers and
Vicky will give hers so And then we'll all come together and
talk together But yeah, so that's all that's all I wanted to
say Yes, yes, yes, yes Mm-hmm, until POV There's so much
dust in here it's making my throat hurt a cough drop.
And then start the game.
I feel like I feel like today is like the most like la la.
Like usually I'll start the game within like 30 minutes or
all.
You know.
I feel so numbity.
So like chillax today.
Come out.
Thank you.
This and more have been long overdue for all the years of
entertainment you have provided.
I hope my sincerity came across.
Oh no, Squirtcher.
I'm sorry.
I don't want you to feel like you have to feel like you have
to apologize and don't know.
Thank you, though.
I won't tease you more.
Unless you want me to.
Thank you, though.
Thank you so much.
Also, I saw that you're membered, so for over a year.
I mean, for two years so what the heck don't even say like
and more
this one's yummy what's the flavor Hachimitsu and Kareen mmm
that's where like the citrusy flavor came from I think
Coolsville sucks where the heck is Coolsville
What is Cardina?
What is the translation?
Burmese Rosewood.
Hmm.
What?
Flowering.
What the heck?
Sounds classy.
Anyway.
Oh, wait, I kind of want to do something.
for the atmosphere.
Let's set the atmosphere.
One second.
Okay.
I'm like, I'm not...
I'm not, um...
Stalling.
There we go.
Ready?
Let's start the game!
My eyes.
Oh, it's so bright.
Wait, it's the Cori!
It looks just like it!
We filmed right here!
My little ta- oh.
A long journey.
A sleepless night.
All that matters now is finding it.
And seeing her.
We're after a woman signed me up!
MV sequel live stream?
We're gonna- oh peer into the distance.
Oh Racks.
Throw the grapple.
Wait.
Oh, I have to hold it down?
Climb up.
Wait.
Wait, can I go up there?
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
I'm afraid I can't say I'm working.
It's busy.
Oh, no, Phil.
Good luck.
Drop by six.
the MV is amazing, the chaotic nature just adds how awesome
it is.
Thank you!
Good luck with the work!
Thank
you!
Is this blood?
I just need to get to the bottom of this place.
Oh!
Oops.
I tanked it?
Oh, wow!
What's...
Uh, oops.
Whoopsie.
Wait, so... Wait, that's probably not how you repel.
Like, the right wait I'm gonna repel down hold on unless
oh holy cow
can I oh I can swing okay Spider-Man moment, actually.
Wait, how do I get longer?
Hmm.
Trying to figure out...
Okay, hold on.
How can we do this?
Oh, maybe like...
Dang, hold on.
Oh, that's okay.
Oh, here we go.
Slide down.
Oh, control.
Ah-ha!
there's whoa there's ghost buildings here well I'm at the
bottom what's this right here breathe in ashes it's not my
friendly neighborhood spider meito you breathe in the
ancient ashes the musty scent of stale air is replaced with
pine and morning dew you can almost see the faint outline of
your village stirring awake you remember it was the day you
left for this place you don't want to remember this it
serves no purpose to you now that these ashes will remember
you oh is this like my village so close so far what's
down here wait hmm okay that's a safe point I suppose Oops.
Bink.
I'm climbing up the rope.
Okay, we're getting used to it.
We're getting used to it.
It's not so bad, I think.
Bink.
Yeah, see?
I don't know where I'm going.
I'm just...
We're going down, down, and I mean, and we're doing a meow.
swinging oh dang it swinging swinging swinging swing swing
swing swing oh new meow song every song is a meow song I
like the sound it makes how's the audio by the way um I do
not have my headphones on so honestly I have no idea how it
Is good?
Okay, thank you.
Oh, shoot.
I get too excited.
Wait, I wanted to look around that other area.
I guess we can go back up.
If you hear something that sounds scary, though, that I
don't hear, help a ghost out.
Let a ghost know that you heard something terrifying and
spooky and spectacular.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, we got health!
Wait, that was just you guys.
See, it pays to...
To explore.
Aha, I see, I see, okay.
I definitely sucked the life energy out of that thing, yeah.
That's what I'm talking about, and I say I'm sucking life
energy.
Alright, um, actually, I don't even know if this is a great
place to go down.
There's not much, um, to grab onto.
Now that I think about it.
Maybe we go back up, actually.
We exit from another location.
You can throw the hook on the floor, then drop.
What do you mean?
Oh!
Oh, I get what you mean.
I get what you mean.
Like this.
And then I go down.
And then I slide.
Like that.
I do a sick, cool move.
Where are we going?
Oh.
We're going down, down.
Yeah, we sloyed.
Down, down by the river.
Do you guys hear something?
Hmm.
Did you hear something?
Spooky sound?
How spooky is this game anyway?
Oh.
Like, what?
Oh, okay.
We have, like, the best rope known to man.
Oh.
Wait!
Oh!
Whoa.
This is fine.
We got ankles of steel.
That's not me at least.
I'm still standing.
Yeah, I fell into the house.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How deep is this place?
Rout, row.
We have to make it there before this guy sees me!
Oh, no, he sees me!
He's fast, but I'm fast, too!
I hear him.
Oh, God!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, shit.
No!
I need to get up there, I think.
I hear him coming!
There's the nope I mentioned.
Oh, man.
Oh, we got crunched upon.
That was stressful, though.
That was stressful.
Oh, we went down this way.
Okay.
Oh, but I'm also full health again.
So that's kind of fun.
It really gets in your ears when you have headphones on.
Well, none of you have headphones on, right?
It did sound like a...
They put the black mold spider dungeon in this game.
Whatever you are thinking of...
Oh, I heard my tummy growl and I thought it was this...
was the guy.
Whatever you're thinking of for the dungeon.
The black mold spider dungeon.
It's like so much worse.
It was just really awful.
You think we can make it over there?
Okay, I didn't have to.
Okay, we're gonna try and get closer to the save point
before we...
Tree.
Whoa!
Wait a second, though.
Oops.
Okay.
Dang.
Maybe here?
I think I'm gonna have to...
Please!
Ugh!
That's okay.
We almost had it.
I think if I had thrown it just a little bit sooner, I would
have had it.
But now I know that's a valid strat.
Wait, can I... Oh!
Okay, you can drop quite a bit before the game is like...
Before the game...
There we go.
It tells you to quit.
Less thoughts, more swinging.
Yeah.
Oh, this is where I was before.
I don't necessarily like this area, but that's okay.
One second.
The rope physics are really good.
Nice.
I think I have to go, like, kind of fast in this game, I
feel like.
It's kind of like a...
Always...
ABS.
No, ABM.
Always be moving.
I think I took damage?
Always be me too.
I can't help it.
I can't help that.
Okay, this is where they come from.
You guys see any?
Okay.
This is scaring me, you guys.
I feel like I hear one.
Ouch.
It's okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Breathe the ashes.
Oh!
Yes!
You see Praxoth.
Praxoth's.
Oh, Thoss.
His kind and sun-weathered smile is gone, replaced with a
solemn line.
your mind he places a hand on your shoulder and you shrug it
off guilt fills your stomach you don't want to remember this
it serves no purpose to you now these ashes will remember
you yay wait was that a person oh it's him but he's just a
ghost he's just like me for real for real wait I already see
the next one that's kind of crazy oh how
far is it
oh my god he's coming he's coming
can you like cut my rope i wonder oh shoot wait i'm swinging
i'm swinging
please grab hook
line and sinker
Please, don't die.
Ouch, ouch.
No!
Holy cow.
We made it?
Yes.
It's okay.
If we die, we get full health again, it seems.
You breathe in the ancient ashes.
You see the shape of her.
It is frail and twisted now.
The coil rot had already done its terrible job and left you
at the pieces.
You smell sickness hanging in the air.
You don't want to remember this.
It serves no purpose to you now.
Is that her frail body?
On the ground?
She's just laying there.
Kind of chill.
Is that the next save point?
Should be chilling?
Kind of cozy?
Looks like a little blanket?
Oh, it is.
Imagine.
Can you imagine like a centipede comes this way?
I get to the top and there's a centipede.
Would that be terrifying?
I wonder if I can like run and throw.
I took a little bit of damage there.
I'm taking, I'm getting my brain damage.
Oops, oops, oops.
The stress is real!
Wait, where was...
Oh, wait, is there health in here?
There is.
If you can figure out how to get to it.
Oh, next to this...
Wait, is the health next to the body is because it's their
spirits?
Wait, that's kind of...
Oh my gosh, I'm actually eating spirit.
Ew.
Where was that now?
I've kind of lost the point that I was trying to get to.
Yeah, I'm eating their essence.
It's so realistic.
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Shoot!
Ouch!
This is fine.
I'm sure 160 minutes cannibalism without fail.
Mint is a cannibal.
I bite at the hand not to feed me.
Who needs knees, am I right?
Exactly.
You breathe in the ancient ashes.
You see the shape of her.
It is strong, hailed, beautiful, but distant.
You remember this moment.
She waited for months for you to return.
Every step you had ever taken was a step towards her.
Seeing her distant shape is unbearable now.
It's too far.
You don't want to remember her like this.
The ashes do, they do be.
remembering a whole lot, huh?
Can I get to that little guy over there?
Well, I think so.
Yummy?
More tree?
What's that down there?
It's like a different color.
I wonder if we can just...
Okay, I think we took a little bit of damage, but not so
bad.
Hoi!
Oh,
what's down there?
So curious.
Mm-hmm.
It's very bright.
What is that?
Is that...
Oh, okay, it's pottery.
I thought it was like the eggs that...
Oh my gosh, my eyes here.
I thought it was um...
Do you guys hear something?
Oh shoot.
I thought it was like the eggs that the centipedes hatched
from or something.
That's what I was trying to say.
Oh, when it...
Oh!
Oh, there's a person there!
So scary!
Oh, that's her!
That's her being far away.
Gosh, that spooked me.
Ouch.
Get me away from here.
That guy's coming to get me.
I hear him.
Uh...
Wait, how did I take damage there?
Oh, shoot.
Um...
I was about to say, like, always be throwing your hook.
And just hope for the best.
Like so.
I need you guys to give me a warning if you hear a thing
because I can't hear so well I don't have my headphones on
oh it's broken no
oh holy cow
I'm basically living on 1hb here.
Is that health?
At least I guess.
I'll try.
Yes!
Whoopsie!
I slipped!
I can't believe my dumb dummy dummy this.
Who's that?
Do you think I can land on this?
I
forgot to put the wet floor sign there.
Oh my gosh.
How did I manage that?
Good.
Creepy Crawly!
He's on to me!
Uh...
Ouch.
It's the only way I could go!
We gotta keep going!
Oh, please.
I feel like he's right on my tail!
Oh.
Uh...
What are you supposed to do here?
Health though.
I'm gonna grab it.
Is that him?
Shit.
Yeah,
I can't...
We sometimes have like pretty chill times and sometimes we
have not so chill times.
Yeah, I think you're just supposed to fall and pray, but I
feel like it's a little unforgiving with how far down you
get without a save point, you know?
oh shoot
section of stuff but it's hard to see okay
hopefully this one is not as bad in terms of crawly after me
okay I would read their super chats but I'm like so scared
of getting bugged.
Oh, come on!
Holy cow!
I will go up.
No, I will go down!
I will go down!
No!
Dang it!
He's after me!
He's so close!
Dang it.
Ouch!
Oh.
Holy cow.
Is that cloud or something to grab onto?
I think that looks like something.
Okay.
This is fine.
Oops.
I already took a chunk.
Great sound design.
Is the creepy crawly that bad?
I wish I could put in headphones.
I'd like to hear.
This ain't looking so hot.
It ain't looking so hot, guys.
Ouch.
My bones.
Wet.
floor.
We made it?
I
thought I saw him for a second.
This game's a little stressful, you guys.
This game's a little freaky.
Run, run, run!
Ouch!
I made it, but at what cost?
Oh my gosh.
I want that save point so bad.
This part is cruel.
Just kill me now.
Here, I'll restart.
I want to die, but the game refuses!
Big jump?
Okay.
Wait.
I'm washed?
Whatever.
That's fine.
As long as we get down.
Did I hear it?
Or am I crazy?
Wait, is it this way?
Yeah.
Apparently in Japan, I'll be making the holy pilgrimage to
Akiba later.
Later today!
It's been hard catching streams, but I only got a chance to
listen to Den, such a new single.
You guys did amazing.
Thank you, we have no danger!
Have
fun in that keeper!
I love it there.
I went- I took a pretty bad route, I think, but...
Oh my god, he's already here!
He's already here!
Am I that slower?
It's fine.
He's fast.
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to swing.
Ouch.
That's okay.
We just got a goal.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
There's nothing here for me to grab.
Uh.
Okay, I just have to drop.
Oh!
Never mind!
I thought... Okay.
Uh, well, that was my bad.
For...
Trusting the process.
Oh.
Oh, I see him.
I don't know which way to go, so...
We're just gonna hope and pray.
Oh, I think it grabbed it, but I slammed into the wall.
Okay.
It's so hard to see in that part.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
So far, so good-ish?
Asterisk?
So far, could be worse?
Okay, drop here.
Ouch.
Stuck.
Okay, that's fine, too.
Alright.
Wait!
Where'd my hook go?
I tried to jump so that I could grab the hook or the hook
could grab the wall and then...
It didn't catch!
We can take the...
A bit of damage here.
Splat is so gross.
Oh, this game is gross.
Oh.
Speed run?
I did see.
There is a speed run mode of this game.
Which I could see people really getting into.
Oh, shoot.
You know what?
Uh, not fine.
Sure.
my ankles.
I wish I could get a little bit of health.
Dang it.
I think you need your ankles.
Says who?
Achilles?
Okay, Achilles over here.
Ugh.
Actually, we will get this.
Some paths are definitely easier than others.
Ouch.
Oh my god.
I always miscalculate the throw.
I always, always miscalculate the throw.
Sorry, I thought I heard something.
Well, now I don't have my headphones on.
I can't, like, be as immersed in the game because I hear,
like, I hear everything.
You know what I mean?
It's an IRL centipede.
I do hear something.
I'm afraid I must drop.
What is that?
One second.
It's freaking me out!
This is where the health is, no?
Oh, I think I hear the centipede, though.
Run!
Turn off your speaker a sec.
No, it's definitely...
It's something behind me.
That I hear.
So not the speaker.
But it's fine.
Let's try going down over this way.
Rather than jumping in the middle of everything.
Get up there.
But I'm just so tempted by the save point.
You know what I mean?
There was one here.
And it broke!
Why did they do this?
Why are they so cruel?
Oh, I made it.
Can I make it in there?
From here?
Wait, it's not a safe point.
It's just health?
Ouch.
Oh.
Okay.
I got scammed for hardcore real
Wait I thought that
So rude I
saw it Yeah me too I saw it I saw it Hmm I mean I didn't
hear it To be fair I did not hear it but I definitely saw
like the thing stop up like it should have hooked oh shoot
thank you you heard it bump off oh my gosh oh my gosh is
that already him no stinking way I'm in a terrible spot
right now.
I guess it grabbed.
But I also...
It's tough.
Like, not hitting the wall.
And not...
Dying.
We made it so far down there.
Where is another save point?
It's so rude.
And then they, like, kind of force you to take damage here.
There,
the sheer...
Thank you.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
I don't think it's around there.
The...
I think I hear him.
I'm not even gonna turn around.
We're gonna go all the way over here.
Are we going to do what we did before?
I'm not even going to look at him.
I looked.
Like a fool.
Why did I do that?
At least this way, we were able to make it down.
But what the heck?
It was just health.
What good is health if I just fall to my death anyway?
Do I hear him?
Oh, shoot.
I can't.
Can't tell.
The creature can't jump.
I think there's multiple of them, no?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oops.
Oh, dang it.
That's not what I meant to do at all.
Apparently some can clear this in sub two minutes.
It sounds like, this feels like spooky getting over it.
You know?
Getting over it with higher stakes.
Oof, ouch my bones.
We're gonna risk it for the biscuit.
What HP in a dream, actually?
Where?
There?
Where's the bridge?
What?
Hmm?
I didn't make it.
Oops.
Oh, there she is.
Okay.
I kind of want to see it up close though.
Oh, it's avoiding me.
Holy cow!
He comes in bunchin'.
He comes down crunchin'.
Oh yeah, he's right there.
Well, that's not so great.
I don't remember what pathway I had done before, but I had
kind of liked it.
He's a cruncher.
Mr. Grinch.
Munch and crunch and on his food.
Well, that was really bad.
I feel like I panicked so much that I can't even remember
what routes I'm taking before.
This sucks!
So I can't even find the ways that like I'm finding routes
that work for me and then I lose them.
You know what I mean?
Okay, This is good, this is good.
Run over here and grab the health.
And then run, run, run, run, run, run.
That's the idea.
This is kind of the strat so far.
Blue Tower.
Welcome to the mountain blue ship.
Thank you.
We're running, we're running, we're running, we're running.
Some two minutes.
be that long, then, it seems.
You just have to gain.
Okay.
Sometimes I hold down shift because I'm, like, trying to
run.
And then, but also, I'm like, wait, that pulls me up.
I need to go down.
Ouch.
We knew we would take the hit.
You're very Very cool, I'm glad you think so.
I wish there was a save point here, though.
Wait.
Nope.
Why did I...
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna retry.
No.
He's right there.
The pressure is too much.
for me to bear.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
You know what?
Fine.
That's okay.
Take damage to save frames.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oops.
Not oops.
Yeah!
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
Yeah, totally planned.
It was actually.
Why else would I have thrown my hook?
Yes.
Oh, perfect, perfect, perfect.
Kind of.
Close enough.
Okay, okay, good, good.
Alright, this is looking promising, everybody.
Though I still...
I still want to go here so we can go around.
I'm still going to follow this track, even if we don't
necessarily need the health.
Entirely.
We'll grab it and then go down this way, because this is
good, this is good.
We're sprinting.
Our life does depend on it.
Oh, wait.
Yeah,
okay.
Yum.
Okay.
Very good.
That's how Indy would do it.
Yeah!
Probably!
You're so right!
This is the Indy Way!
Indiana Jones!
No,
I don't want to go in there.
That seems like a death trap.
Oh, come on!
Don't be like that.
Let's just slide down a little.
Okay, took a little bit of health there.
That's okay.
I wish I knew where he was.
Oh, is there anything for me to grab onto here?
No?
I guess I could have fallen and tried to swing there.
I feel like exploration is not in this game.
I would have missed anyway!
What the?
Ah!
What just happened?
Oh, oh, oh, it was scripted.
It was scripted.
Oh my goodness, thank goodness.
Oh, I thought the centipede.
She just came and snapped my rope!
Look at all the people that tried.
I'm the chosen one!
I won't become a rock!
My health though.
My health is at zero.
The ashes will give me new life, right?
You breathe in the ancient ashes.
Oh, okay.
it coats your throat and lungs you fight the urge to cough
and your eyes water
they warned you this place was filled with illusions nobody
warned me of the bugs tricks of the mind and tangible and
ruinous well the music is good reversing White Knuckles They
claimed all who come here meet the face of regret
That oh White Knuckles is a game isn't it?
That there was no greater folly than to lose Your life for a
memory
Regrets I've had a few The shape of her manifests Behind
your eyes
She's not disappearing this time though
She's not disappearing this time though And all thoughts of
regret or folly are silenced.
I like the music.
I turned it to a rock!
No!
I look like a little Pompeii person.
Made by humans.
If I ever make a game, I have to say made by ghost.
Thank you for playing.
What a...
What an interesting...
Mint fan stone.
No!
What an interesting concept.
Reach the bottom in normal mode.
Oh, sandbox mode.
I can see people really getting into creating maps of this
and like speed running this and stuff yeah what we still
love you even if you were a rock it's funny because um i
don't think i don't know if i ever told you guys this i
don't remember but um i was like you know i could come back
as a ghost but what if i you know uh after after heaven what
if instead of coming returning as a ghost what if i was
reborn what if i uh you know what if i said so long after
life and i was thinking i really would like to be reborn as
a gargoyle so i was playing with that idea of uh being
reborn as a gargoyle you rock me though What if I was a
rock?
I could have been a rock!
Sandbox means something completely different to cat people.
A gargoyle.
No, a gargoyle.
And that's a rock fact.
But yeah.
No, I'm still a ghost, though.
I decided not to...
Not to...
Go to the light.
Wait.
Nightmare mode?
It is faster and smarter.
Kilns have been destroyed.
No, thank you.
Oh, it's...
Sure.
Let's try it real quick.
Look at my goyle, bro.
Oh, it starts us at the hole.
I just need to get to the bottom.
Do you think it can come up here?
Oops.
Oh.
we're gonna take bigger risks more challenges I can see
people be beating this in sub two minutes I'm not gonna lie
if you are a madman I could see it for sure you know oops I
could see it this is not going to end well says you I think
it's gonna end great Cue the subtle foreshadowing.
See?
I'm a pro now.
Come out, come out, wherever you are.
How fast are you?
Trying to figure out where I want to go from here.
Oh.
See?
I'm a professional now.
Where is he?
I was promised centipede to impede my path.
Maybe we go this way.
Took a little bit of damage there.
Oh, we made it.
The centipede is ourselves.
He sentipede in my way.
That's not the hole.
No.
That looks like a little ritual going on there.
So they did a ritual and became rocks?
Or...
Oops.
Wait.
There's my hook.
Oh.
Okay, I give up.
Back to main menu.
I said today might be a bit shorter anyway, so...
Cool, and like I said, there is...
Where is it?
A speed run mode.
Speed run mode.
Wait, if I click it...
There we go.
What does it do?
Does it give me a timer?
Let's see.
I was the centipede!
Oh, it does!
I'm stressed, I'm stressed, I'm stressed!
Don't time me!
If I die, does it restart?
I guess it...
Well, if I die...
Oh, wait, okay.
I'm having severe blindness from the light.
I'm not panicking.
And
we're not panicking.
We're not panicking.
Oh!
It's already been one minute.
I'm...
It's over for me.
I'm so...
I'm never making the leaderboards.
My mom will never be proud of me.
What did I land on?
okay
just hug the wall and slide hug the wall and slide it works
every time hug the wall and slide look at that okay it's
already almost been two minutes i told you anybody that come
can complete this in sub two minutes is an actual monster.
Oh, it's a pig attention.
We're fine.
Never, never, never punished.
Alright, because we're never punished, I'm gonna do a crazy
bit here.
Watch this.
Oh, nothing picked me up.
The timer still says two minutes!
It's over for me.
It's so over for me.
Thank you guys for Idols of Ash.
Thanks for letting me talk a lot about the music video
earlier.
I hope you guys found my stories interesting.
It was fun to talk about.
I'm going to keep packing.
And I will see you guys later.
I will see you.
have a schedule for this week.
I just have to, um, I didn't even know what I was gonna do
today, so.
Oh, thank you, thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much.
Thanks for sharing.
Thanks for listening.
Such a fun music video.
I wish, can I raid into the music video?
Can I have you guys listen to it against your will.
Let's see.
burn on.
Doesn't, maybe only mute, only, only streams.
Then setzu.exe.
It does not let me.
That sucks.
Oh well.
Um, click the link in the pinned.
Anyway.
Good luck packing!
Wear a mask for dust.
I should probably.
Thank you.
Dorko, thank you so much for the pig!
Give it the stream, you are truly our rock.
Our cute and gloriously solid and ectoplasmic?
Rock holding our sanity intact and making our world silly in
food.
Hope you have a great night.
Try not to breathe in too much ancient ash while packing.
There is a lot in here, so...
I mean, we're gonna go listen to it regardless.
You should listen to it now!
Again, again!
Otsumito, everybody!
Have a good day, have a good night, have a good time, zone,
and I will see you when I see you next.
I know it was said earlier, but if you like this, I'd really
recommend White Knuckle.
It's the same, but climbing and with spooky...
Wait!
Takedo burrito.
I have a... Thank you for the super chat, first of all.
I have a funny story.
I had a dream.
I took a nap earlier, because my allergy medicine has just
been making me so drowsy.
You can't tell now because I'm all wired, but I had a dream
that I was going to play a climb.
This was literally just earlier.
And I was told some friend was just like, you have to play
it in 3D, you have to play it in 3D.
And I was like, why?
And they were like, because think of all the panty shots.
So if I play White Knuckle, I'll do it in 3D.
Your initial strategy to fall to the bottom with the fake
save is actually the speedrun strat.
It's how this one guy made it down to two minutes.
Oh, no kidding!
I was so close.
Okie dokie!
Dream friend is so real for that.
I know, right?
Anyway, okay.
Otsumi-to-it-a-shai!
Thank you, everybody!
My silly dream story.
Maybe I was thinking of this game, and I was like, oh, it's
the opposite of climbing.
If I climb again and again, I should do it in three.
The, I guess, I don't know.
Anyway, okay.
Thank you everybody.
Bye bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.